[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
t-cell analysis fine-tuning your t-cell
research workflow step-by-step
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by maltene biotek
to learn more visit meltineybiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
our speaker will answer questions via
the email address you provided during
registration
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr marcelo stein global marketing
manager translational immunology miltoni
biotek
dr stein you may now begin your
presentation
welcome everybody to the third webinar
of our t cell series t-cell analysis
fine-tuning your t-cell research
workflow step by step
in the next 45 minutes you'll learn
about the best diesel analysis products
by melting a biotech
so enjoy
please briefly acknowledge the displayed
disclaimer
so let's begin with a brief company
presentation well miltoni biotech was
founded in 1989 by stefan milton himself
and is the largest owner managed company
in germany
we have two main sites in germany one in
bergesh gladbach where the headquarters
are located and one in tetero where the
gmp manufacturing facility is located we
have subsidiaries in 28 countries and
distribute to an additional 73 countries
currently we employ over 4 thousand
employees worldwide
our mission is to serve the needs in
life science research and to translate
new scientific findings into clinical
applications
as for the agenda first we will have a
brief look at the biology and function
of t cells as well as at the concept of
workflows and the hallmarks of max cell
analysis
next we will have a look at our
highlight t-cell analysis products
we start with flow antibodies and kits
and then we will learn about our flow
cytometry and in measuring instruments
and finally we will of course briefly
sum a sum up
let's briefly introduce so the t cells
in general and of course our max flow
analysis solutions
well t cells play as effectors of the
immune system an integral role in the
adaptive immunity
they can be subdivided broadly into
several phenotypically and functionally
distinct subsets such as the helper
cells cytotoxic tequila cells
deregulatory cells as well as the rather
heterogenic group of unconventional t
cells comprising for example natural
killer t cells and gamma delta t cells
t cells are the only immune cells that
are able to form a long lasting
immunological memory that helps to
respond faster and more efficient to
already experience threats
key surface markers that are always
mentioned in regards to t-cells are of
course the t-cell receptor tcr that
recognizes antigens as well as the
activating co-receptors cd3 and cd28
those three surface markers are present
on all t cells
furthermore core receptors cd4 and cd8
are the defining markers for t helper
cells and cytotoxic tequila cells
respectively
to exert their functions as effectors of
the immune system t-cells release
cytokines to communicate with their
environment and to cause various effects
such as promoting inflammation
includes
interlocking two interlocking iv
interferon gamma two on necrosis factor
alpha transforming growth vector beta
and interlocking 10.
t cells are most relevant in both
maintenance of health as well as
fighting diseases
last but not least these properties make
t-cells ideal tools for immunotherapy
where t-cells for example are
genetically modified as car t-cells to
attack cancer specifically
a quick look at t-cell biology covers
the basic aspects when talking about
t-cell phenotypes and functions mostly
surface markers cytokines and
transcription factors come into play as
defining molecules that can be most
efficiently analyzed well mainly by flow
cytometry approaches
well although our best known products
are indeed the microbeads and isolation
kits we are not just a cell separation
company
we actually cover the whole experimental
t cell workflow from cell separation to
cell analysis the topic of today
including also sample preparation as
well as cell culture
we provide thereby solutions for each
step of your experiment
and today we concentrate on t cell
analysis please note we already covered
t cell separation and t cell culture
earlier this year in two different
webinars available as recordings on our
website
so our teaser portfolio is indeed large
one way to keep a good overview is to
divide
our t-cell products into our different
main workflow technologies
sample preparation for everything that
has to do with preparing your sample for
example tissue or blood before you
isolate your t-cells to start your
experiment
the gentlemax tissue dissociate and
dissociation kits are here the hallmark
products
then we have cell separation our
classical microbeads and isolation kits
in all their variants to isolate
efficiently t cells and subsets
cell culture everything needed to
culture activate and expand your t cells
from media to cytokines to antigens and
last but not least cell analysis
t cell flow antibodies flow kits and
also instrument for flow cytometry
sorting and even imaging
well although it may be now easier to
get an overlook of our product world we
thought that maybe the best way to
arrange our large tc portfolio our
distinct workflows specifically designed
for your experimental needs
thereby we cover as focused workflows
amongst others regulatory t cells car t
cell research gamma delta t cells tumor
infiltrating leukocytes polarization of
t cells antigen and virus specific t
cells and of course activation and
expansion of t cells
with these comprehensive workflows you
can easily choose the products relevant
for your specific field of interest
please keep in mind the diesel portfolio
is growing by the day and the respective
workflow overviews are all constantly
evolving and work in progress so check
regularly for updates
by the way
you might notice throughout the
presentation these smaller small yellow
buttons paired with a little click hand
symbol just like the one on the lower
right
in the pdf version of this talk you can
access the respective product pages
marketing materials videos and protocols
by simply clicking these buttons as
there are all hyperlinked
while getting your whole workflow from
miltoni biotech means ease of mind
standardization reproducibility and
organization of an experimental workflow
become much more feasible
miltoni as supplier for the whole diesel
workflow means that all reagents fulfill
the same high quality criteria and the
order process can be streamlined
thereby harmonizing the steps of an
experiment as well as automation and
upscaling are easily performed
getting all products from military
biotech guarantees smooth procedures and
less errors since for example our cell
separation is tested for compatibility
with our flow cytometry and our media
for compatibility with our cytokines and
so forth
moreover having miltoni as full supplier
for the whole workflow means also
getting full support for every step of
your experiment thanks to our great
scientific support team
moreover a hallmark feature of milton's
workflow solutions is this seamless
seamless translation from a research
setting into a clinical setting and back
thanks to our max gmp portfolio as well
as cell manufacturing platforms such as
such as the clinimax prodigy
well when applying flow cytometry
approaches for t cell analysis of course
precision is key
however unwanted variability and
analysis results can have many different
sources
such as donor variability
inconsistent panel design
reagents and specificity unprecise
instrumentation and operator and
analysis variability
here you see just a small example of one
of our publications in the journal of
human gene therapy
immune cell composition greatly varies
between donors depending on possible
disease states and starting material
preparation
all these sources of variability should
ideally take into account and
compensated for for most efficient flow
analysis
that is why max flow cytometry stands
for highest precision and covers all
aspects of flow cytometry flow analyzers
flow sorter imaging systems and all the
respective reagents are included
and this shows in the width
width of our diversity of our flow
portfolio
not only for t cell analysis from
instruments to software from antibodies
to flowcast in even customization
solutions we offer indeed the whole
range of flow analysis
so let's start with our highlight flow
products our flow antibodies and flow
reagent kits
first we have the reaffinity recombinant
antibodies
being recombinantly engineered we have
full control over their genetic sequence
and can express their affinity
recombinant antibodies in mammalian
non-hybridoma cell systems
this means that we affinity antibodies
exhibit highest purity and lot
consistency for greater reproducibility
that they can undergo a most stringent
in-house validation
and have no need for tedious and costly
fc receptor blocking
and they require only one universal
isotype control for maximum convenience
and cost saving
most recently even releasable versions
for label-free cell sorting were added
to our infinity portfolio
additionally reaffinity antibodies also
are part of our unique multani biotech
tested panels various detection kits and
pre-mixed cocktails including the
innovative stain express dried antibody
cocktails
your affinity antibodies are hereby
readily available in hundreds of
specificities and are best combined with
our propriety via dye fluorescent
antibody conjugates
thereby our wire dyes are bright with
superior mean fluorescence in tendency
for excellent signals distinct with a
high stain index for clear population
discrimination
and hassle-free since they are ideal for
multi-color experiments due to low
compensation
all this makes raffinity recombinant
antibodies the ideal choice for flow
analysis since traditional
since traditional hybridomas are not
standardized in nature
more info on that can be found following
the various links on this slide
and indeed if comparing classical
hybridomas to recombinant reaffinity
antibodies it shows that without fcr
blocking hybridomas bind unspecifically
leading to an overestimation of the
actual cell frequencies
we affinity antibodies
instead do not need any fcr blocking and
always bind precisely leading to lower
background and reproducible
results well and now when comparing also
antibody preparations of classical
hybridomas to our affinity antibodies
in this case it is all mao cd4
monoclonal antibodies analyzed by mass
spectrography
it becomes obvious that the classical
hybridomas contain a large amount of
non-functional contaminating light
chains
while raffinity antibodies are without
these contaminations this difference
comes from the recombinant nature and
preparation of the affinity antibodies
and the pure mammalian expression system
as for the biodyes or propriety
fluorophores also bear really some nice
advantages
when comparing directly fluorescence
intensities of dyes with similar spectra
violets generally are superior as shown
here in the comparison between horizon
v500 chrome orange and our wire green
furthermore biodyes come in many
varieties as shown here in this brief
example by combining them with classical
fluorophores the possibilities are
really endless
here i'd like briefly to show
just some exemplary flow antibodies that
you can choose from to create your own
panel
depending in which context you want to
analyze your t-cells be it in
development activation exhaustion or any
other type of phenotyping
please note that the relevant markers
may differ of course between the species
and the panel should be adapted
accordingly
however to ease things up we also offer
our multibiotech tested panels
as well as our concluded antibody panel
builder
which is a web-based software tool that
you can access to build your own panel
just follow here again the links below
to have a look
apart from classical antibodies in flow
panels we also offer a wide array of
flow analysis kits containing of course
our proven antibodies to analyze t cells
in really every way
namely for the analysis of cytokines for
phenotyping and of course viability
these flow kits and essays but also our
tested panels cover applications and
parameters to assess
such parameters as purity for example
after enrichment viability the phenotype
of course the immune cell composition of
your sample the activation and
exhaustion states of your t-cells the
transduction efficiency the potency of
for example you are killing car t cells
and many many more
so let's have a look at the first three
of our convenient ready to use flow
analysis kits
such as first the rapid cytokine
inspector kits
as all-in-one no worries solutions that
combine surface markers staining with
intracellular cytokine staining for the
analysis of activated cd4 and cd8 t
cells in the fastest way possible
second the max black cytokine kits for
determining concentrations of up to 12
different secreted cytokines in cell
culture supernatants
and third the eight color
immunophenotyping kits for flow
evaluation of various leukocyte subsets
for example monocytes neutrophils
eosinophils and tb and nk cells in your
sample
importantly all of these kits are
compatible with the fast and convenient
express modes on the microsquad
analyzers
these smart
software modules automate analysis and
thereby not only speed it up but also
eliminate a human error thanks to
automated gating and analysis templates
but later we will come we will hear more
about that
make sure to have a look at the new
promo video for the flowcase as well as
the express modes and the maxplex
webinars by following the respective
links on this side slide
consequently i'd like to present some
applications
examples using the three aforementioned
kits
well the rapid cytokine inspector is the
ideal solution for the analysis of rare
antigen activated
t cells it combines extra and
intracellular staining of subtype and
activation specific surface markers and
cytokines at the same time
in this example t cells with in the pbmc
context were stimulated with cmv and
peptide pools so our captivators pp65
and immediate early and the frequency of
cmv reactive cd4 cd80t cells were
analyzed by assessing interferon gamma
expression
hereby
classical intracellular staining with
the handmade protocol and our rapid
cytokine inspector kits were compared
and as you can see
the rapid cytokines inspector performed
at least as good as the classical
intracellular staining but yields the
benefit of a much faster protocol and
less washing less cell handling and then
of course less cell loss
hereby a classical intracellular scaling
can take up to hours while the rapid
cytokine inspector
with the rapid cytokine inspector you
are done in only 45 minutes further
applications include assessment of a
sample's immune status or testing of
leukophoresis material for
virus-specific cd4 and cd8t cells
as said before the rapid cytokine
inspector is of course compatible with
the express mode for automated data and
analysis on the max quant analyzers to
even speed up your analysis more
also in the context of cartesian
analytics the rapid cytokines vectors
come in quite handy as the readout is as
straightforward as it gets here in this
example car t cells were co-cultured his
target cells either expressing the
intended c9 and antigen or not
as you can see
see these three positive
t cells and alternatively you can with
the rapid cytokine spectacles also
differ differentiate between cd4 and cd8
positive t cells they're assessed for
interferon gamma tnf alpha and
interlocking two intracellular cytokine
expression
co-culture of car t cells with antigen
negative target cells did not lead to a
proper diesel activation with no or only
low cytokine expression
whereas co-culture of car t cells and
antigen positive target cells as you see
here
led to strong expression of interferon
gamma tnf alpha and interleukin-2
our next application examples involve
the max plague cytokine kits
so the second kit that i presented
before
also here car t cells where co-culture
with target cells is expressing the
respective target antigen in this case
cd20
in this example we elevated evaluated
the functionality and antigen specific
killing of manufactured cartesians using
the maxplex assays
in more detail we co-cultured the cd20
transgenic positive target cells in this
case it was ruggy cells with our cd20
directed car t cells
beat from healthy donors or cancer parts
patients and measured cytokine secretion
and as shown here upon direct contact
with the target cells the cd20 directed
car t cells secrete high amounts of
vector cytokines like interferon gamma
interlocking 2 and tnf alpha they're
verifying their functionality
in the next example
we will have an application example of
the eight color immunophenotyping kit
the circuit that i presented before
here a single cell suspension of a
dissociated tumor was stained with the
eight-color immune phenotyping kit and
analyzed by fluorocytometry using the
max quant analyzer
to determine the immune cell composition
in the dissociated tumor sample
the tumor of the tumor was first
dissociated with the gentle max tissue
dissociator and the respective enzyme
kits then the suspension was stayed with
stained with the eight-color
immunophenotyping kit human
and
based on the pre-defined displayed
gating strategy using the express modes
you can precisely identify the amount of
total lococytes
as well as the cd8 positive they see the
eight
cd4 positive t cells the nk cells the
nkt cells b cells cd40 plus monocytes
subsets and so forth
but of course we have more kids to offer
when it comes to flow cytometry so apart
from the three aforementioned flow kits
we also offer further interesting these
analysis hits in our flow portfolio
one of our more recent highlight flow
analysis kits is depicted here the
sarskoff ii t-cell analysis kits human
these all-in-one kits allow the
efficient stimulation and sensitive
analysis of sarskoff-2 reactive t-cells
in human pbmc or whole blood samples
after stimulation with sarskoff to
peptivate a peptide pool cells are
stained with our optimized flow panel as
depicted here on the upper right and
analyzed for example on a muxquad flow
analyzer
depending on the version of the
kits the kits hereby include asarskoff
2peptivator of choice
as well as the whole sarskoff 2 diesel
flow panel consisting of 8 to 9 nine
re-affinity recombinant antibodies
moreover all needed buffers and controls
are included such as the positive
control cytostem and if needed the live
debt marker viability fixable die
as you can see we can beautifully detect
for example interferon gamma dnf alpha
and cd 154 expressing sarsof2 reactive
cd4 and cd8 positive t cells after
stimulation with a mix of sarskof2
protein s protein n and protein m
peptides
of course also the other markers as
depicted here in the panel can be easily
assessed on the flow cytometer
please keep in mind although the kids
are called sarskoff ii t-cell analysis
kits we have also a version without
peptivators that is perfectly suited to
analyze any kind of antigen-reactive
t-cells as you are here free to choose
any stimulus
of choice
in the following nice data sets we
stimulated pbmcs of sarskoff 2 reactive
donors with the aforementioned
sascof2peptivator peptides pools as
indicated
a mix of cmv and ebv peptivators was
used as positive control
and as you can see we pre-gated then
either on cd4 or cd8 positive t cells
and assessed cd 154 and tnf alpha
expression as well as cd69 interferon
gamma expression respectively on the max
quant analyzer
the reactive donors t cells respond
specifically to the stimulation
stimulation in comparison to the
negative control with the expression of
the respective activation markers in
cytokines
moreover i want to point out a cell
analysis and separation product that is
absolutely unique the cytokine secretion
assays
they allow to detect and enrich viable
cytokines
secreting cells from mouse and human
samples
cytokines are immobilized on the surface
of the secreting cells by the so-called
catch reagent
basically
thereby the cell labeled itself with its
own cytokines
in a second step the immobilized
cytokines are then labeled with
fluorophore conjugated antibodies called
detection reagent and can then be
detected viably without intracellular
staining on any flow cytometer
in an optional search step the
fluorophore cytokine secreting cells can
be specifically enriched and used in
downstream assays by using
antifluorophore magnetic beads
so consequently our cytokine secretion
assays come in two versions
for flow detection only we have the
so-called detection kits
for the separation
of viable cytokine secreting cells we
have the detection and enrichment kits
including the additional enrichment
steps by a max column
please see in this application example
of the il-17 cytokine secretion essay
detection and enrichment kits how nicely
antigen specifically stimulated t cells
can be enriched even from low
frequencies to clearly visible levels
above background
solely based on their il-17 secretion
antigen-specific t-cells were stimulated
within the pbmc context with a c
albicans peptivator for 16 hours or left
untreated and then enriched using the
il17 secretion sa cell enrichment and
detection kit
before enrichment
with the cytokine secretion assay kits
levels of reactive t cells beat in the
unstimulated control or in the
stimulated samples are hardly visible we
are talking about really really rare
cells
however after enrichment
analysis is much clearer
now when gating on the cd4 positive t
cells and looking specifically
scd-154 expression it becomes apparent
that mainly the cd4
plus cd 154 plus t sets express in this
example interlochen 17.
also in our second example the cytokine
secretion and ss detection and
enrichment kits work very efficiently
also to enrich viable virus-specific
t-cells based on their cytokine
secretion
here pbmcs of a cmv positive donor were
stimulated for four hours with cmv
lysate
the responding cells were stained and
isolated according to the secretion of
tnf alpha and interferon gamma using
this
respective secretion essay cell
enrichment and detection kit
and as you can see
in the stimulated samples
a strong population of cytokine
secreting cd4 positive and cd8
positive t cells respectively was
enriched in the unstimulated control
sample however no cytokine secreting t
cells were detected after enrichment
moreover in teaser analysis of course
also analysis of cell viability plays an
important role in a variety of contexts
also here we offer quite an array of
different solutions such as the
viability fixable dyes
annexing five kits the seven aad
staining solution of course propedium
iodide
life's a life dead cell discrimination
kits as well as staining solutions such
as huxst darby drag 5 and sidetrack
orange
again you can directly access the
respective product pages using the links
on this slide below
staining can for example be used to
monitor cell fitness in regards to their
storing conditions
in this example
for manufactured car t cells first
storage at 4 degree for 48 hours and
second freezing thawing both with
subsequent culturing at 37 degrees were
compared
we observed that cell fitness basically
the amount of
apoptotic as well as dead cells was
higher
after the freezing throwing cycle than
just storage at 4 degree that way
your manufacturing process can be
coordinated in regards to your needs and
be of course optimized
in an uh in another extraordinary
application example of viability
stainings car t cells mediated target
cell killing was assessed via in vitro
killing assays
car t cells and mock trans transduced t
cells were co-cultured
with antigen positive and antigen
negative target cells
in this example the antigen the target
antigen was cd20
and of course different rate ratios
between car t cells and target cells in
our tex max t cell medium
after co culture incubation at 37 degree
and prophetium iodide stating of the
sample was it was performed
automatically by our max1 flow cytometer
just before sample acquisition
and dpi positive cells were measured
the measuring was then performed using a
specific express mode which is an automa
automated and standardized analysis
software exclusive to our max quant
analyzers
the percentage of kilt so tropium iodide
positive target cells is normalized to
the control setups for example the mox
transduced cells or the antigen
target antigen negative cells
and as you can see
in the data on the right here killing of
target cells amounted to about 40
percent at a one to one
ratio beat from
car key cells obtained from healthy
those donors or patients
our flow kits are rounded off with our
outstanding car detector reagents these
reagents were developed to stain
and
detect transgenic t cells expressing
cd19 cars on the cell surface
the reagents come ready to use and with
a muted idg-1 fc for minimal background
staining so that no fcr blocking is
needed
the binding thereby of the reagent to
the car t cells simulates
the invivo binding of the car to the
respective tumor antigen
car positive t cells can hereby be
easily detected with highest precision
in this example cd19 positive car t
cells made up around 20 percent of the
whole
cdc positive population in the samples
of course our car detection reagents
come also in additional specificities
such as cd22 pcma or cd3m33
the next group of diesel analysis
highlights products are our flow
cytometers circus and imaging
instruments
namely our flow analysis and sorting
instruments of the max quant series
first we have the max quant analyzer
powerful benchtop flight flows the
tomatoes with up to 16 optical
parameters the clue here is that they
allow for full automated acquisition
using a robotic sample collector with
the express mode software volume modules
even data analysis is then automated and
free of human error the small bench of
cytometers fit easily under every
flowhood adding further to operators
hefty for example when working with
contaminated samples
second we have the max quant tied to
cell sorter
opposed to classical droplet sorters the
macron title allows for the most gentle
sorting and highest viability even for
rare and fragile cells
thanks to its unique microchip sorting
technology
furthermore the closed and sterile
cartridge system makes it tied to the
ideal machine for a gmp environment
well a little bit more in detail the max
quant analyzer are not only small
convenient powerful but also offer high
degree of automation for startup
shutdown and cleaning
sample labeling and processing
calibration and qc
fully automated volumetric cell counting
and of course data analysis with the
express modes
this makes them simple to use even for
unexperienced flow beginners
last but not least with our support and
the 21 cfr part 11 implementation you
have every experiment under full control
so what are actually these
aforementioned express modes exactly
well the express modes are software
modules in the maxwell analyzers that
automate flow analysis with standardized
algorithm-based data evaluation
results become more standardized as
operator variability is minimized due to
a lack of manual intervention and
reduction of human error
this results in highest reproducibility
with identical flow analysis independent
from the operator
express modes are simple to use and
offer a quick and robust analysis for
easy integration into sops with the
validated automated analysis concept
several of our flow analysis kits such
as the aforementioned rapid cytokine
inspectors the max black sidewalk and
kits the 8 color amino phenotyping kit
as well as very specific flow panels for
example for car diesel analysis are
compatible with the express modes and
your analysis will be automated
please have a look at the respective
webinar by following the link below
as just mentioned we have apart from
cytokine and phenotyping flow kits also
a variety of car t-cell re-affinity flow
panels that are compatible with the
automated express mode analysis to
standardize your cartesian experiments
thereby we offer for example tested
panels amongst others for cartesian
transduction efficiency car t cell stem
cell memory phenotyping cartisal
differentiation cartesian persistence
cartesian proliferative ability
cartesian activation and finally as
highlighted here as an example cartesian
exhaustion
after the max quant analyzer flow
cytometers i'd like also to have a
closer look at our max quantitative cell
sorter this gentleman under the cell
sorters
with its unique capability namely the
most gentle sorting in the closed
sterile cartridge system the title is
ideal for a gmp clinical environment not
only in the fields of car t cells and
t-rex but also for antigen
virus-specific t-cells including also
tumor infiltrating leukocytes
so let me point out that the title is
already part of several clinical cancer
trials involving antigen
specific or in this case
better set tumor-specific t-cells
respective data and testimonials can be
found of course on our website
worthwhile mentioning is of course also
the tied to safety in virus research the
title works without internal fluidics
and applies a sterile enclosed cartridge
system for maximum operator safety
sorting purity is of course guarantees
of you as you can see here in the
example below their car t cells were
sorted after expansion staining with our
car detector reagent
to over 99 purity
on top of all that a really fantastic
novelty in our portfolio are our new
imaging systems maxima and the ultra
microscope light sheet microscopes
these systems allow the visualization of
t cells and others within a tissue
context thereby for example new car t
cell targets may be identified the
distribution dynamics of tumor
infiltrating leukocytes and tumor tissue
assessed and the deep phenotypic
analysis of patient samples and to the
tumor microenvironment is possible
hereby the maxima imaging platform for
ultra high content imaging applies the
renowned mixed technology spatial immune
cell distribution including their
phenotype is assessed within tissue and
cell conglomerates but a sequential
staining of hundreds of markers
in contrast traditional staining
techniques allow maybe the staining of
three to six markers giving only an
incomplete picture
this analysis of hundreds of markers
within a single sample includes of
course automated sample processing and
strong software analysis and imaging of
all types of fixed samples from tissue
to single cells
have a look at the product video by
clicking the respective links on the
left
on the other hand
our light sheet microscope of the ultra
microscope family enables you to
visualize whole biological systems in 3d
moving the samples through the light
sheets allows the generation of sharp
and bright 3d images of for example the
tumor microenvironment thereby really
giving you the full insight of the tumor
immune cell interaction
in this context the ultra microscope 2
is a highly flexible light sheet
microscope for 3d imaging of cleared
samples the ultra microscope blaze is a
fully automated light sheet microscope
3d imaging of multiple samples
please have a look at this impressive
video taken with the ultra microscope
blaze that shows a mouse xenograft of a
human pancreatic carcinoma cell line
with infiltrating car t cells in 3d
and here we come to an end of this
presentation and therefore i'd like to
briefly sum up
as mentioned before the variety of our
t-cell product is best organized in
comprehensive workflows following your
scientific interest
consequently please find here listed our
highlighted application workflows with
clippable links to the respective
application on protocol pages as well as
to further info material and webinars of
course there are more and our selection
is growing by the day
however our current highlights include
polarization of t cells with protocol
and cytokine combinations for the most
efficient polarization of your cd4
positive t helper cells the regulatory t
cell workflow with all needed solutions
for the isolation as well as the
expansion and of course flow analysis of
rare t-rex in a translational setting
the car tisa research workflow covering
all steps from t-cell isolation to
activation to transduction and finally
car-t potency analysis for fully
translational and functional generation
of car key cells in a research or small
scale setting
the tumor infiltrating leukocyte
workflow to efficiently associate
dissociate tumor tissue
and isolate even the rarest
tumor-infiltrating leukocyte
the antigen-specific t-cell workflow
optimized for the specific stimulation
of antigen-reactive t cells as well as
the isolation and analysis of these
extremely rare cells in many different
contexts
and finally the covet 19 virus-specific
t-cell workflow that covers each step
from stimulation to enrichment to flow
analysis of sarskoff to reactive t cells
especially important during the current
pandemic
have a look at the respective
application pages and webinars to find
out more and of course also here we will
update and expand the highlight
workflows regularly so please have a
look for updates
although that was quite an extensive
overview of the tesla portfolio you have
just to remember three easy things
well first we offer more than just t
cell separation
second we cover the whole t-cell
workflow
and third we offer a solution for every
pain point in your experiment
so have all the success with our
innovative and complete user portfolio
as displayed here in this full featured
overview
again please keep in mind the tesla
portfolio is growing by the day and the
respective workflow overviews are all
work in progress so check their back
regularly for updates
please also follow these links here on
the lower right
to access the respective diesel
application product pages as well as to
download our t-cell brochures
talking about more information brochures
of course you can find a variety of
helpful marketing materials downloadable
from our web page www.multibiotech.com
for diesel specific applications just
click on the button on the lower right
you'll find flyers brochures webinars
and videos protocols and data sheets
customer reports application notes
scientific posts and data sets
and of course you can also directly
always reach out to the responsible
sales representative in your area
and hereby i end this presentation with
this nice picture of our company campus
in baggage club at night so thank you
very much for your attention
thank you dr stein for your time today
and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor miltoni biotech for
underwriting today's educational webcast
questions will be addressed by the
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event
until next time goodbye
you